l'artisanat le commerce sont maillon
essentiel de nos zones rurales
monsieur arros l'ancien
secrétaire-général d'une chambre de
commerce d'industrie et d'artisanat
pardon de métiers de l'artisanat
bonjour à toutes et à tous simplement
vous dire effectivement j'étais donc
jusqu'à moggi dernier il ya six mois
secrétaire général de la chambre de
métiers de l'artisanat de lot-et-garonne
est responsable de la formation
professionnelle dont l'apprentissage sur
toute la région aquitaine
juste pour vous dire effectivement que
nous avons besoin de se tenir
effectivement l'économie dite de
proximité
il faut l'encourager mais surtout la
soutenir aujourd'hui et elle est très
importante alors pourquoi la soutenir
bon je vais faire un constat très simple
parce que un c'est un lien
incontournable sociale de nos
territoires tout le monde s'accorde à le
dire il n'y a aucun souci là-dessus lien
incontournable oui mais aussi aussi en
fait c'est une le secteur des métiers
comme le commerce d'ailleurs c'est une
attractivité résidentielle aussi ça
favorise l'attractivité résidentielle
alors une petite chose aussi qu'on ne
nous dit pas souvent mais le secteur des
métiers comme le commerce la petite
entreprise locale
elle a effectivement elle est très très
pauvre en matière de bilan carbone
par contre elle et ce secteur est très
riche en matière de d'utilisation des
productions locales très pauvre en bilan
carbone mais riche de l'utilisation des
productions locales ça je crois qu'il
faut le dire et puis bon éléments
sociologiques je je je me plaît toujours
à dire l'artisanat et le commerce pour
moi qu'il est défendu pendant 35 ans
c'est je le qualifie de respiration
humaine respiration humaine dans un
monde de cannes a largement et
terriblement besoin
voilà donc ça c'est le premier jeu en
faisant voeu non sans un petit peu aux
propositions là les propositions en
milieu rural j'en ferai deux ou trois la
première proposition c'est revenir à un
équilibre un équilibre qui a été détruit
par justement
les stations des grandes surfaces etc
alors je dis bien peut-être que
politiquement nous sommes arrivés à un
moment où il faut ralentir mettre le
pied sur le frein
voir gelée effectivement l'extension des
des grandes surfaces
je vous rappelle que la france par
rapport à ses voisins européens
elle a un record assez important de
mètres carrés par rapport à l'habitant
et surtout effectivement que je parle
d'équilibré effectivement que cet
équilibre soit profite un petit peu et
beaucoup à aux petites entreprises
alors comment peut-on le faire on peut
le faire un deux ou trois manières vous
parliez du fisac tout à l'heure on est
passé sous le gouvernement actuel de 20
millions si ma mémoire est bonne à 19 on
a dû diviser par deux je rappelle que le
fisac c'est la taxe parafiscale occuper
la grande distribution pour le fonds
d'intervention au sauvegarde de
l'artisanat l'artisanat et du commerce
eh bien faisons en sorte un de revenir
au moins à la dotation première deux
peut-être de l'enrichir et 3
responsabilisons les élus locaux
nos maires les présidents de communautés
commune des présidents d'agglomérations
et permettons leur de réfléchir à l'
équilibre qui le leur dans les petites
dans les petites communes et de pouvoir
financièrement grâce aux fonds au fisac
effectivement d'intervenir de présenter
des pas de porte des baux commerciaux
etc et de voir quels équilibres qu'ils
doivent conserver jugeant que ça c'est
important
c'est une des premières mesures
une deuxième mesure une deuxième mesure
qui est tout aussi importante c'est de
s'attacher à réfléchir à la fiscalité
qui est la fiscalité des zones rurales
je crois que là il ya un gros dossier
alors avancé des pourcentages serait
peut être pas fortuit mais je pense
qu'il faut réfléchir à au moins dix ont
exonéré en partie les installations en
milieu rural
et pendant un certain nombre d'années
qu'il eu assez assez important je
rappellerai qu'un lot-et-garonne un
président de conseil départemental du
conseil général de l'époque était que
jean françois poncet bien connu ce qui a
été ministre et c'est un grand talent et
innover alors peut être que ces vieilles
recettes et à le remettre être remise au
goût du jour ce qu'on appelle le
tremplin rural il avait pour favoriser
l'implantation en milieu rural inventé
le tremplin rural qui permettait de
donner de attribuer une légère
subvention aide à l'entreprise qui est
artisanale ou commerciale qui allait
s'installer dans une commune de moins de
2000 habitants
j'ai vu que nous avons 86% des de notre
territoire
deux des communes qui sont effectivement
sous le seuil des 2000 habitants et bien
une attribution d'une dune d'une aide
financière assortie d'une obligation de
formation parce que dans le milieu rural
effectivement là que le côté commercial
le numérique l'un a parlé évidemment est
très important voilà voilà une une idée
effectivement qui est importante
alors après et je ne terminerais là vous
allez me dire je vais vous parler
d'apprentissage mais comment on peut
relier l'apprentissage et la ruralité et
bien je vais vous dire il ya un fort
lien un très très fort bien le et ça on
le sait pas suffisamment
si je vous dis que c'est ce sont les
entreprises en milieu rural et vous
savez que la petite entreprise forme 80
forme 90 % des apprentis aujourd'hui les
apprentis qui sont 400 4410 mille
aujourd'hui en régression constante sous
le gouvernement que l'on connaît bien
aujourd'hui 1 alors que les objectifs
était fixé à 5000
mais on est en régression de lui pour
cent de 4% et chaque année en baisse et
ont fait un pas en avant et un pas en
arrière et rien ne va eh bien écoutez
aujourd'hui les artisans en milieu rural
et les commerçants du rural sont ceux
qui embauchent le plus apprentis en
aquitaine
c'est une grande région il paraît que
c'est la plus grande de france un
territoire et bien en aquitaine le monde
rural compte 90 95
apprenti pour 1000 entreprises le monde
urbain 60
voyez la différence nous avons une
différence énorme
alors réfléchissons en plus le monde
rural à la double peine pour un apprenti
c'est la peine du logement et de
l'hébergement parce qu'il faut les
bergers loin du centre de formation etc
alors si nos artisans en milieu rural et
nos commerçants sont capables
d'embaucher des apprentis alors qu'ils
ont des difficultés notamment en ce qui
concerne l'hébergement
bien ça veut certainement dire quelque
chose voilà alors j'en ai terminé bon
pour cela il puis de grâce remettons la
petite entreprise au goût du jour
merci